The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN ESSIGMANN: Let's take a
look at storyboard number 10.
Back in earlier
sessions, we talked
about the detail of glycolysis.
One of the points
that I emphasized
is the fact that it's
necessary to maintain
redox neutrality in the
cytoplasm of a mammalian cell.
It's also necessary to
maintain redox neutrality
and prokaryotic cells,
not just eukaryotic cells.
At the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate dehydrogenase step
of glycolysis, NAD+ was
consumed and converted to NADH.
That means we have to find a
way to convert NADH back to NAD+
in order to make glycolysis
a continuous process.
Back in lectures three and four,
I said that there were three
ways to convert the NADH back
to NAD+ These were alcoholic
fermentation in anaerobic cells.
Homolactic fermentation, again,
in an anaerobic environment.
And the third is
respiration, which occurs
in the presence of oxygen.
I'm going to loop back now
and revisit this topic.
I want to spotlight
three general strategies
that cells use to achieve redox
neutrality in the cytoplasm.
The first is lactate
dehydrogenase.
The second is called the
glycerol-3-phosphate shuttle.
And the third is called the
malate-aspartate shuttle.
Panel A of this figure shows
the cytoplasm working in concert
with the mitochondrion.
You can see depicted
on the left,
the pathway of glycolysis.
In the middle,
pyruvate dehydrogenase.
And to the right, the citric
acid cycle or TCA cycle,
which we just covered.
There are two important boundary
conditions for the discussion
we're about to have.
The first is that
oxaloacetate is,
as I mentioned earlier,
present only in very small
concentrations within
the cell and especially
in the mitochondrion.
As a consequence,
the mitochondrion
does not have a transporter
to allow it to escape.
In other words,
its concentration
is preserved at
about one micromolar
inside the mitochondrion.
The second boundary condition
concerns the fact that NAD+
and NADH, as well as NADP+ and
NADPH cannot go directly across
the mitochondrial membrane.
So in other words, there
are two separate pools
of this nucleotide co-factor.
One in the cytoplasm.
One in the mitochondrion.
I'll come back to the
importance of the two
pools in just a few minutes.
Let's look first,
here in panel A,
at the mechanism by which
lactate dehydrogenase achieves
redox neutrality
in the cytoplasm.
We've already covered this,
so this is a bit of a review.
Note that you see NAD+
getting converted to NADH
in the cytoplasm.
That's at that GAPDH
or glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate dehydrogenase step.
The hatched lines
that you see represent
the flow of electrons.
In other words, electrons
flow from glucose
and they end up in NADH.
Then the lactate
dehydrogenase enzyme
transfers the electrons
from NADH into lactate.
So these electrons
from glucose are
involved in the reduction
of the ketone functionality
of pyruvate into the alcohol
functionality of lactate.
And that's where
the electrons stay.
The other product of this
reaction, as you'll see,
NAD+ which is now available
to enable the oxidation
of the next molecule of glucose.
What happens to the
lactate that's produced?
In a working muscle
cell, that lactate
will escape from the
cell, go into the blood,
and then go to the liver
or another organ that's
capable of doing the
pathway of gluconeogenesis.
As I've mentioned in the
past, gluconeogenesis
is a pathway by which
non carbohydrate
precursors, such as lactate,
are built back up into glucose.
Keep that working
muscle scenario in mind,
because I'm going to
come back to it later
when I talk about
physiological responses
to stress, such as what I'll
call the fight and flight
scenario.
That's all I'm going to say
for now about the LDH shuttle.
That is, lactate
dehydrogenase shuttle
in panel A, which is the
first of the three pathways
by which redox neutrality is
maintained in the cytoplasm.
The second pathway
to retain redox
neutrality is the
glycerol-3-phosphate shuttle.
This pathway is particularly
active in the brain
and in skeletal muscle.
Once again, follow
the hatched lines
to follow the path of electrons
as they go from glucose.
And ultimately, in
this case, they're
going to end up being deposited
into oxygen to form water.
Starting at the top, you see
in NAD+ being reduced to NADH
at the glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate dehydrogenase step,
GAPDH.
Next, we're going to
temporarily borrow
a molecule of dihydroxyacetone
phosphate, DHAP.
DHAP is a ketone.
And what we're going to do is
deposit the electrons from NADH
into the ketone functionality
to make the alcohol,
glycerol-3-phosphate.
The source of the
electrons was NADH.
And now you've accomplished
your chemical goal,
which was to restore the
NAD+ pool -- the cytoplasm,
but we borrowed a molecule of
dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
And we've somehow
got to get that back.
Let me point out, at this point,
that the reduction of DHAP
to glycerol-3-phosphate
was accomplished
by the cytoplasmic form of the
enzyme glycerol-3-phosphate
dehydrogenase, which catalyzed
step 2 on the storyboarded.
We're going to deal more with
coenzyme q in the next lecture.
But for now, it's a
molecule, specifically
a quinone, that's easily reduced
to its hydroquinone form,
called QH2.
The structures of q, in
QH2, are shown in the box.
QH2 is in the
mitochondrial membrane.
In glycerol-3-phosphate
dehydrogenase
the mitochondrial
version of it is
present in the outer part of the
mitochondrial inner membrane.
Like NADH and FADH2,
QH2, the hydroquinone,
is what I've called a
mobile electron carrier.
QH2 is going to allow the
electrons that started out
in glucose or in any
LDH of the gap DH step,
to flow through the electron
transport chain, which we'll
come to in the next lecture.
And flow into oxygen, which
is reduced to form water.
This terminal reduction
is shown in step five.
Effectively, in the
glycerol-3-phosphate shuttle
we're using oxygen in order to
oxidize NADH back to NAD+ And
once again, maintaining a
constant supply of NAD+ is
necessary in order to make
glycolysis a continuous
process.
Panel C shows a third
strategy for maintaining redox
neutrality in the cytoplasm.
This is called the
malate-aspartate shuttle.
and this pathway is operative
in heart, liver, and kidney.
To the left we see the
production of NADH,
just as we did in the
previous two small pathways.
At step one, let's
assume that there's
a molecule of oxaloacetate
present as part
of the cytoplasmic
pool of organic acids.
Oxaloacetate or OA is ketone.
And the cytoplasmic form of the
enzyme malate dehydrogenase,
working in the reverse
direction from the one
that we see operative
in the TCA cycle
is able to reduce the
oxaloacetate to malate.
We just reduce to ketone
OA to an alcohol malate.
In step three, the
accumulating malate
is transported by a
malate transporter
into the mitochondrial
matrix, which is, of course,
the location of the TCA cycle.
At this point, we're
going to be using one
of the steps of the TCA cycle.
Specifically, we're going
to use malate dehydrogenase,
the mitochondrial
version of the enzyme
this time, to convert
malate to oxaloacetate.
That reaction is an oxidation.
We use the mitochondrial pool
of NAD+ to carry out that
oxidation.
In effect, we're using the
electrons that came in from
malate to reduce NAD+ to end
NADH in the mitochondrion.
Now, take a careful
look at step four.
Looking to the left you see the
hatched lines go all the way
back to glucose, which was
the source of the electrons.
To the right, the hatched
lines by step five,
go to the electron transport
chain all the way to oxygen.
We haven't done the electron
transport chain as yet.
So you're just going to have
to trust me for a little while.
There's an enzyme,
NADH dehydrogenase,
in the mitochondrial inner
membrane that will take
the electrons from NADH and
eventually regenerate the NAD+
in the mitochondrial matrix.
In step five, we're
taking the electrons
from the NADH produced
by malate dehydrogenase
and entering those electrons
into the electron transport
chain.
Then, in a manner that's
quite similar to what
we did in the previous shuttle,
the glycerol-3-phosphate
shuttle, those
electrons are going
to be transferred to
oxygen to make water.
Before I go on, let's
review a little bit.
Between step one and step
two in the cytoplasm,
we deposited electrons into
oxaloacetate to make malate.
That step restored in NAD+
levels in the cytoplasm,
which is what we
wanted to accomplish.
However, we've consumed a
molecule of oxaloacetate.
And as I've mentioned
before, the cell
has to try to preserve the
concentration of this very
precious molecule.
We now have to find a way
to restore oxaloacetate
that we borrowed in step one.
Now let's look
back at step four,
where malate was
converted to oxaloacetate
in the mitochondrial matrix.
Because the molecule of malate
came from the cytoplasm,
this is a net increase in
the mitochondrial matrix
of one unit of malate
and, ultimately,
one unit of oxaloacetate.
We need to find a way to get
that molecule of oxaloacetate
back out into the
cytoplasm, in order to make
the shuttle a continuous one.
In the co-factor
section of 5.07,
JoAnne taught us
about the ways that
pyridoxal phosphate and
pyridoxamine work, in order
to put amino groups into organic
acids, such as oxaloacetate.
And that's what's going
to happen in this case.
Oxaloacetate is converted
into its amino acid homolog,
aspartic acid.
Why did we do this
emanation reaction?
Well, there's no way to get
oxaloacetate directly out
of the mitochondria because
there's no transporter for it.
But there is a good transporter,
the apartheid transporter,
that will take aspartic
acid out into the cytoplasm.
So the oxaloacetate is
converted, temporarily,
into aspartic acid
in the mitochondrion.
And that aspartic
acid then slips out
through its transporter
to the cytoplasm.
Once in the cytoplasm, there's
a similar pyridoxal mediated
mechanism to deaminate
the aspartate
to regenerate the cytoplasmic
molecule of acetate
that we borrowed at step
one a few minutes ago.
In panel D I summarize.
That we've looked at three
different small pathways that
enable the cytoplasm of the
cell to always have enough NAD+
to oxidize glucose to pyruvate.
These pathways are first, the
lactate dehydrogenase system.
Second, the
glycerol-3-phosphate shuttle.
And third, the malate
departed shuttle.